[Applaus]
[Musik]
wladimir putins angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine ist in vollem gange mittlerweile
scheint klar zu sein dass putin mit
einem blitzkrieg gerechnet hat der auch
vollkommen unrealistischen annahmen
beruht anscheinend hat ihn seine
isolation und paranoia während der krise
dazu gebracht sich immer mehr mit ja
sagern zu umgeben welche ihm die einst
zur potemkin ein idealisiertes bild
seine armee der ukraine der eu und nato
und auch seines eigenen landes
gezeichnet haben ja hätte er sich doch
lieber unsere video zum zustand der
russischen armee angesehen und auch
jenes in dem wir die ukraine als falle
für russland identifiziert haben aber
das problem des touran ist ja ein
systemisches er muss seine kritiker
mundtot machen um an der macht zu
bleiben ohne kritiker dritte jedoch
immer mehr von der realität ab
[Musik]
irgendwann glaubt dass selbst ihn liegen
die er über sein umfeld in der welt
verteilen lässt er ist in einem selbst
verstärkenden lügen kreislauf gefangen
und diese lügen feedback club machte
auch aus den putin von einst den putin
von heute er hat unwiderruflich das
image eines coolen pokerspielers
verloren der mehrere züge im voraus
durchdacht hatte er hat den widerstand
des ukrainischen volkes maßlos
unterschätzt seine generäle haben nicht
bedacht dass ihre ukrainischen
konterpart die gleichen politischen
militärakademie besucht haben und alle
taktiken des klassischen
enthauptungsschlag aus dem stegreif
rezitieren können für diese
fehleinschätzung spricht auch die
tatsache dass die 140 mann starke
invasionstruppen zumeist junge und
unerfahrene wehrdienstleistende viel zu
klein war um ein so großes land wie die
ukraine zu besetzen sie rechneten damit
dass sich viele ukrainer ihre truppen
anschließen aber das passierte einfach
nicht aber auch dies haben wir in jedem
video erläutert indem wir klargestellt
haben dass eine version nicht im
interesse russlands sein kann der
diktator an keiner dachte auch er könne
die eu auseinander treiben was ihm
seitens der politiker in deutschland
vielleicht auch gelungen wäre wenn die
öffentlichkeit die internationale
gemeinschaft um die medien nicht klar
gezeigt hätten dass sie ihren diese
heuchelei nicht mehr durchgehen lassen
und an dieser stelle auch wenn wir sonst
mit den medien sehr kritische springen
müssen wir einfach alle loben die sich
die es verdient haben
[Musik]
putin dachte er könne die ukraine zum
spaß bekommen und jetzt gut vielleicht
bekommt er sie noch aber wenn man zu
einem untragbaren preis ich werde meine
diese videos noch mal genauer darauf
eingehen welche geopolitischen szenarien
sich aus diese aktuellen lage ergeben
vor allem im hinblick auf den spieler
china zunächst möchten wir jedoch einen
blick darauf werfen was der ukraine
eigentlich blühen würde wenn sie den
russen in die hände fielen und glaubt
mir danach wird allen klar sein warum
die ukraine sich so verbissen wehren und
warum ihn nicht eine sekunde derart gute
gedanken in den sinn kommen wie sie nun
hoffe ich von vielen gratis der
fettesten zu hören sind die noch schön
sicher in ihren warmen stückchen auf der
hiesigen seite des nato schutzwalls
setzen es wäre doch einfach das beste
sie würden sich ergeben dann gäbe es
wieder frieden pustekuchen was wir euch
heute zeigen sind nicht nur
anhaltspunkte beweise dafür dass das was
politik für die menschen in der ukraine
im falle seines entzugs plant nichts
anderes wäre als die pure hölle auf
erden also macht euch auf etwas gefasst
dieses video wird nichts für schwache
gemüter seid ihr bereit gut dann schauen
wir uns doch erst mal an wie das alles
angefangen hat
am montag den 21 februar unterzeichnete
der russische präsident wladimir putin
dekrete zur anerkennung unabhängigkeit
der volksrepublik tor jetzt grund der
volksrepublik nur hans im osten der
ukraine der russische präsident wies
außerdem seien verteidigungsminister an
die russische armee unverzüglich gehen
diese beiden neuen republiken zu
entsenden um eine friedenserhaltenden
operationen durchzuführen was natürlich
aus dem munde putins alles andere als
frieden bedeutet und es dauerte nicht
lange bis man die konsequenz zusammen
die russische regierung selbst hat die
mit den neuen volksrepublik um
abgeschlossene verteidigungs und
sicherheitsvertreter zur ratifizierung
an die duma weitergeleitet die auswahl
politik hatte zuvor bereits vorher
gesagt dass dieser schritt die
vollständige anerkennung der
unabhängigkeit dieser beiden republiken
mehr als wahrscheinlich war es ist ein
schritt der teil des üblichen moskauer
spielplatz ist und etwas das wir bereits
in den fällen von transnistrien
abchasien und südossetien gesehen haben
wir haben auch vorher gesagt dass in
diesen schritt bereits die saat für den
krieg vorhanden ist aber dazu später
mehr die stationierung russischer
truppen in den selbst ernannten
volksrepublik und vernetzt und lohans
gestellte das erste formelle eindringen
russische truppen in rechtmäßiges
ukrainisches gebiet ab und war ein
eklatanter verstoß gegen die minsk zwei
vereinbarungen es handelte sich um den
auftakt zur invasion die bald darauf
folgen sollte zunächst behauptete der
ukrainische präsident wladimir selensky
dass dieser präsident war eine klare
verletzung der ukrainischen souveränität
und damit zwei vereinbarungen darstelle
aber lediglich die aktivitäten der
russischen armee in der region sei 2014
legalisiert habe die ukraine rief
daraufhin den alarmzustand aus
mobilisierte tausende von reservisten
und leitete vorbereitungen auf den
überfall der ukraine nein das ist eine
realität die jeder mehr oder weniger
befürchtet hatte die von moskau geläutet
wurde und die sich dann leider bestätigt
hat russland hatte der ukraine zu diesem
zeitpunkt bereits zu lande zu wasser und
in der luft umzingelt
zu diesem zeitpunkt war den meisten
ukraine klar welche zukunft sie erwarten
würde wenn sie sich nicht maximal zur
wehr setzen sollen und den besten
anhaltspunkte dafür boten ihm die
geschehnisse die sich in den selbst
genannten volksrepublik und jetzt grund
genug heißt ereignet hatten aus diesem
grund wollen wir unsere analyse genau
mit der betrachtung jene zwei separaten
gebiete beginnen denn dort finden wir
den schlüssel dafür warum putin gemäß
seiner menschenverachtenden logik keine
andere wahl hatte als den krieg
loszutreten also was geschah in diesen
republiken und was sagen sie uns über
die zukunft einer potenziell russisch
besetzten ukraine aufgepasst
[Musik]
die neuen volksrepublik
seit ihrer selbst ausgerufenen
unabhängigkeit im jahr 2010 wurden die
neuen publikum fast vollständig vom rest
hätten keine isoliert vom rest der
ukraine und auch praktisch vom rest der
welt mit ausnahme russlands natürlich im
laufe der jahre haben sich zu einem der
undurchsichtigsten am stärksten
abgeschotteten und militarisierten
gebiete der welt entwickelt doch um
herauszufinden wie es ihnen eigentlich
ergangen es wird mit uns zunächst
eigenen grundlegende fakten ansehen um
uns zu orientieren bis russland am 24
februar 2022 den sturm entfesselte war
die volksrepublik tornetz etwa 8900
quadratkilometer groß und hat er etwa
2,3 millionen einwohner der mann den du
gerade auf dem bildschirm sicht ist
dennis buschening ihr anführer vor
seinem durchbruch als separatisten boss
war übrigens an eine betrügerische steht
als system sowohl in russland als auch
der ukraine beteiligt man sieht also der
mann weiß wie man die dinge anpacken
muss auch wenn seine bemühungen wohl
lächerlich waren gegenüber den profis
von comex wirecard und coop das zweite
set artisten gebiet die volksrepublik du
kannst war etwa 8.300 quadratkilometer
großen hatte 1,6 millionen einwohner
insgesamt handelt es sich also um einen
17.300 quadratkilometer großes
no-go-area über dass der ukrainische
staat ab 2014 die kontrolle verloren
hatte das entspricht etwa der fläche
sachsens die offizielle bevölkerungszahl
dieses gebiet betrug 3,0 millionen
einwohner die tatsächliche dürfte
allerdings viel niedriger gewesen sein
dass aufgrund der enormen bevölkerungs
verschiebungen durch den 2008 begonnenen
konflikt verursacht wurden schwierig ist
sie genau zu bestimmen
[Musik]
am 22 februar 2014 floh der damalige
präsidentin karin und verbündete moskaus
viktor janukowitsch aus der hauptstadt
und verließen als folge der durch die
euro an revolution ausgelösten proteste
und genau da begann der sturm
[Musik]
russland reagierte auf die euro meinte
an revolution mit der annexion der krim
durch die berühmten grünen männchen die
sich später nicht als außerirdische
entpuppen sollte ein herbe enttäuschung
für alle autofans ok hatte mal wieder
recht behalten die alle einfachste aller
theorien darf man wie dazu es handelt
sich einfach nur um russische soldaten
nicht gekennzeichnete uniformen dieser
hat den aufstand im osten des landes
erst so richtig an doch während die
einnahme der krim für sie recht
reibungslos verließ waren die aufstände
im osten der ukraine geradezu couch die
proteste in donetsk und lohans
gemeldeten bald in einen bewaffneten
konflikt zwischen der neuen ukrainischen
regierung und den von moskau
unterstützten lokalen milizen zunächst
rückten die prorussischen rebellen
schnell vor und übernahm die kontrolle
über fast die gesamte region donetsk und
lohans
der gegenangriff der ukrainischen armee
und insbesondere der freiwilligen
bataillone zwang ausland jedoch panzer
flugabwehr batterien und langstrecken
artillerie zu entsenden um die offensive
zu stoppen und die ukraine zu singen
einem waffenstillstand zuzustimmen und
das zweite abkommen zu unterzeichnen von
da an bis 2022 bleed die frontlinie mehr
oder weniger stabil die vereinbarung von
menschen zwei waren ein versuch den
konflikt zu beenden
das von frankreich und deutschland
vorangetriebenen von den usa skeptisch
beäugt abkommen erkannte die ukrainische
souveränität im gegenzug dafür an dass
kiew den rebellengebieten einen
besonderen autonomiestatus einräumte
natürlich waren die definition waren
ließen viel interpretationsspielraum was
dann auch dazu führte dass sich am ende
keine seite an ihr wort hielt
darüber hinaus wurde der konflikt nie
wirklich beendet auf beiden seiten kam
es immer wieder zu schützen und
artillerieattacken insgesamt hat der
konflikt zwischen 14.000 20 tausend
menschenleben gefordert mindestens zwei
millionen menschen vertrieben mit
anderen worten die minis zwei
vereinbarungen waren eine weitere dieser
wortreichen europäischen operationen
voller guter absichten die aber im
grunde genommen niemand wirklich
geglaubt hat nicht die usa nicht die eu
muss man schon gar nicht und natürlich
nicht einmal die unterzeichner selbst ja
und so sind die neuen so genannten
volksrepublik in donetsk entstanden zwar
ist der artisten gebiete die sich in
einem permanenten virtuellen
kriegszustand mit der ukraine befanden
die demokratischen institutionen dort
wurden über den haufen geworfen ein
ultra nationalistische konservatives und
militaristische modell wurde
durchgesetzt und viele bin ich sogar die
meisten großen unternehmen und
produktionsanlagen wie bergwerk oder
stahlwerke wurden enteignet oder moskau
freundlichen oligarchen zugeschanzt eine
art arisierung auf russisch die
natürlich auch der ukraine droht wenn
sie russland einnehmen sollte konkrete
beispiele gefällig da wäre der fall der
senior django einem können russischen
investor der dort hatte die wertvollsten
vermögenswerte kontrolliert daneben
wurde auch ein hartes politisch polizei
staatliches modell eingeführt das starke
erinnerungen an sehr dunkle zeiten deckt
es ist ihnen gelungen in den besetzten
gebieten ein sowjetisches system wieder
aufzubauen und zwar nicht das politische
system der 1960 er und 70 er jahre
sondern das sowjetische system der 900
30er und 40er jahre mit kerkern mit
folterkammern ein system in dem sie
menschen ihr leben für immer ruinieren
wenn man es wagt etwas negatives über
dieses republiken und ihre behörden zu
schreiben oder zu sagen stanislav roman
autor und journalist aus donetsk diese
ganze entwicklung hat natürlich sehr
schwere konsequenzen denn haltet euch
fest vor 2014 handelte es sich um eine
der wirtschaftsstärksten und am besten
entwickelten regionen in der gesamten
ukraine also aufgepasst
[Musik]
der absturz
heute erscheint es kaum vorstellen was
zu sein aber noch vor einem jahrzehnt
war soll jetzt einer der wichtigsten
austragungsorte der fußball
europameisterschaft euro 2012 ein top
sportereignis das von der ukraine und
polen gemeinschaftlich ausgerichtet
wurde für die austragung des wettbewerbs
hat sich die stadt herausgeputzt ein
großer teil der stadt wurde restauriert
und renoviert ein neuer flughafen wurde
gebaut straßen wurden instand gesetzt
und neue hotels wurden eröffnet und das
war auch gar nicht so ungewöhnlich die
regionen donetsk und lohans gebildeten
historisch den sogenannten rostgürtel
den schwer industriellen
wirtschaftsmotor der gesamten ukraine
ein wichtiges bergbau und
industriezentrum hier befinden sich
schon seit dem beginn der industriellen
revolution des 19 jahrhunderts die
größten stahlwerke des landes 1869
gründete der walliser john hughes mit
seinem aus england mitgebracht modernen
know how und 100 facharbeitern eine
metallurgische fabrik mit einer siedlung
für seine arbeiter aus dieser siedlung
sollte später das heutige donev
hervorgehen dass manchester oder
ruhrgebiet der ukraine und nicht nur das
donetsk war 100 jahre später auch die
heimat wo der hauptsitz des imperiums
von rinat achmetow dem reichsten mann
der ukraine eine milliardär dessen
vermögen vom ford auf rund 7 milliarden
dollar geschätzt wird ob das alles wird
heute die eine vergangenheit aus einer
anderen welt
die infrastruktur liegt in trümmern die
mobilfunk und internet abdeckung ist
bestenfalls als lückenhaft zu bezeichnen
die wirtschaftstätigkeit ist
zusammengebrochen arbeitsplätze sind
verschwunden oder etwa die hälfte der
bevölkerung ist in die übrige ukraine
nach russland oder in andere europäische
länder insbesondere polen ausgewandert
natürlich haben auch alle
internationalen unternehmen und
geschäfte reißaus genommen am anfang war
die begeisterung für die donezker
volksrepublik groß alle riefen dvr dvr
dvr jetzt gibt es nur noch viel
enttäuschung die wirtschaft dort ist
zusammengebrochen die arbeitsplätze sind
weg es gibt dort nichts gutes alexander
grewe exzellente aus der region donetsk
heute sind diese beiden republiken zu
stark verarmten regionen geworben zwei
orte die im wesentlichen von schmuggel
und subventionen aus russland leben die
vorher ertragreichsten kreise der
ukraine hängen nun zu 100% am tropf der
russische staatskasse ohne jegliche
perspektive
eigentlich ist dort jetzt alles
russische offizielle währung ist der
rubel ihre bürger erhalten russische
pässe sie haben zugang zu russischen
sozialleistungen und ihre führer sind in
putins partei eingetreten die
selbstständigkeit und unabhängigkeit von
der sie und putin immer schwadronieren
ist ein witz
selbst das wort autonomie wäre schon
eine maßlose übertreibung ohne
zustimmung aus moskau könnten sie noch
nicht mal ihre eigene klospülung
betätigen und ich so gut sieht alles
andere als rosig aus ohne internationale
anerkennung werden investitionen und
jeglicher handel extrem schwierig sein
erschwerend kommt hinzu dass us
präsident joe biden nach der anerkennung
der unabhängigkeit der beiden regionen
durch russland alle us unternehmen und
einrichtungen oder bürgern untersagt hat
sich direkt oder indirekt an
investitionsprojekten exporten importen
krediten finanzierung und andere
geschäftsbeziehungen mit diesen gebieten
auch nur zu beteiligen viele andere
länder auf der ganzen welt von kanada
über australien bis hin zur europäischen
union haben dies ebenfalls getan
denn jetzt und lugansk sind von der
internationalen gemeinschaft
abgeschnitten was bis vor zehn jahren
noch der wohlhabendste ort der ukraine
war ist jetzt eine riesige ruine
interessanterweise waren es die übrigen
die ukrainische städte im dom bass die
am meisten von dieser entwicklung
profitiert haben wir sprechen von
städten die in den letzten jahren viele
arbeitskräfte und unternehmer aus den
strukturierten gebieten aufgenommen
haben dies gilt zum beispiel für kopf
der zweitgrößten stadt der ukraine eine
stadt die historisch eng mit russland
verbunden ist und eines der wichtigsten
zentren der sowjetischen
rüstungsproduktion war
[Musik]
eine stadt die prorussische rebellen
2014 kurzzeitig besetzt hatten bis sie
von einheimischen und einer schnellen
eingreiftruppe der ukrainischen armee
vertrieben worden dabei handelt es sich
um eine stadt in der 2010 noch
schätzungsweise kaum ein drittel der
bevölkerung loyal gegenüber der
ukrainischen regierung in kiew war und
auch das scheint wie eine realität aus
einer anderen welt zu sein bereits vor
putins angriffskrieg lagen dort die
zustimmungswerte für die ukrainische
regierung weit über 70 prozent
verantwortlich waren dafür drei dinge
erstens putins andauernde drohgebärden
zweitens die erfolgreiche reformpolitik
der regierung selensky welche den
menschen in der ganzen ukraine egal ob
eine russische oder anderer herkunft
hoffnung macht dass die ukraine hält
nicht den sprung aus ihrem dasein als
postsowjetischer mafia staat schafft
eine hoffnung die ihm putin nie und
nimmer bieten kann und last but not
least der für alle menschen in der
grenzregion deutlich sichtbarer
unterschied in der wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung jener gebiete in denen
moskau das sagen hat oder
in anlehnung an die worte mit denen bill
clinton seine präsidentschaftswahl
gewann
economy putin nun putin interessierten
clintons alte weisheiten nicht die bohne
wohl auch nicht in sachen drogen konsum
zumindest sieht er in letzter zeit ganz
so aus als würde er ganz kräftig
inhalieren und nicht nur das aber im
ernst ich denke dass der größte feind
moskaus nicht die nato oder irgendwelche
nazis in der ukraine sind sondern
schlicht und ergreifend die fehlende
zukunft eines eigenen politischen
gesellschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichen
modells wie sollen die ukraine
angesichts der lage in russland selbst
nicht gehen und westen schauen sie haben
ist in der vergangenheit getan tun es
jetzt und werden es weiterhin tun ich
meine das versteht sich von selbst und
bot ihnen verstand ist auch
er wusste ganz genau dass in die fälle
bei den ethnischen russen in der ukraine
längst davon geschwommen waren während
er sich mit zeigen asymmetrischen
operationen beschäftigte wurde der point
of no return überschritten no return to
russia und anstatt seine niederlage in
frieden einzugestehen versucht er nun
den sieg im krieg zu senden in seiner
anerkennung der republik war bereits die
saat des krieges enthalten schaut euch
mal kurz an
darauf ist dunkel eingefärbt jedes
gebiet zusehen dass die selbst ernannten
publikum ab 2014 kontrollierten und in
heller farbe ist gebiet das sie
eigentlich beanspruchten
russland unterstützt die vollen
gebietsansprüche der ukrainischen
separatisten in den augen der moskauer
machtclique war dies zusammen mit ihrem
nazi geschwurbel der perfekte vorwand
einen angriffskrieg loszutreten es
überrascht nicht dass die konsequenzen
nicht lange auf sich ließen es war der
beginn der westlichen reaktion
22 februar joe biden verhängt eine welle
von sanktionen gegen russland wegen der
invasion der ukraine der us präsident
nimmt erlitten einige banken und
staatsschulden ins visier und sagt dass
weitere maßnahmen folgen werden falls
putin weitermacht australien kanada und
japan verhängen wegen der ukraine krise
sanktionen gegen russland mittlerweile
folgten weitere sanktionsmaßnahmen wie
zb der ausschluss russlands aus dem
swiss system die russische zentralbank
musste daraufhin die leitzinsen auf
atemberaubende 20 prozent erhöhen
unserer meinung nach reichen diese
sanktionen bei weitem nicht aus aber
dazu später mehr denn mittlerweile ist
offenbar geworden welche zukunft putin
für die ukraine plant
[Applaus]
staatliche russische presse agentur ria
nowosti hat versehentlich ein dokument
veröffentlicht und dann fasst sich
wieder zurückgezogen welches viele dinge
offenbart es zeigt nicht nur dass putin
mit einem zwei bis dreitägigen
blitzkrieg gerechnet hat nein es enthält
auch eine schreckliche vision es
offenbar den plan für eine neue
weltordnung in der vor allem russland
und china das sagen haben werden die
unabhängigkeit der ukraine wie auch
weißrusslands wird als schreckliche
katastrophe bezeichnet die nun
korrigiert werden und wenn das schon
schwere kost ist dann lasst euch mal auf
der zunge zergehen in welchem ort
getriebe greift wenn es darum geht die
zukunft dieser staaten zu zeichnen in
astreiner anlehnung an nazi sprecher ist
davon die rede dass die russische
invasion der ukraine die lösungen der
ukrainischen frage sei mehr noch der
name der ukraine und die entsprechende
ethnische bezeichnung sollen ausgelöscht
werden künftig soll nur noch von
großrosseln für die bewohner der
jetzigen russischen föderation von
weißrussen und von kleinbussen die rede
sein den ideologen im kreml reicht es
also nicht aus das ukrainische volk
seine unabhängigkeit zu berauben nein es
soll auch noch umbenannt und durch
seinen neuen namen gebrandmarkt und
gedemütigt werden das ist wohl die rache
dafür dass sie nicht die liebe ots in
den letzten jahren akzeptiert haben und
natürlich wird auch eine solche
einteilung im kasten in hirn und unter
menschen auch ganz klare konsequenzen
für jeden kriselnde haben
wir verfügen über glaubwürdige
informationen die darauf hindeuten dass
die russischen streitkräfte listen von
identifizierten ukraine erstellen je
nach einer militärischen besatzung
getötet oder in lager geschickt werden
sollen die russischen streitkräfte
werden wahrscheinlich tödliche maßnahmen
einsetzen um friedliche proteste zu
verstreuen oder auf andere weise gegen
friedliche formen des vermeintlichen
widerstands der zivilbevölkerung
vorzugehen sorry aber wer vor diesem
hintergrund noch seine gas und benzin
rechnung priorisiert oder sich einen
frieden durch aufgabe wünscht sollte
sich mal ganz schnell eine gründlichen
realitäts oder gar charakter check
unterziehen in unserem letzten video
haben wir euch bereits dazu aufgerufen
ihre bundestagsabgeordnete zu wirklich
kategorischen sanktions schritten zu
ermuntern kanada hat bereits eine art
bild einkäufe aus russland komplett
gestoppt nun müssen auch die usa und die
eu folgen vor allem beim erdöl erdgas
und bei der kohle klar es wird eine
temporäre finanzielle belastungen geben
aber je vollständiger in dieser russland
lockt da und ausfallen wird desto kürzer
wird auch die belastungs zeit ausfallen
gerade die starke innovationen welche
sich putin in der korona krise gegeben
hat spricht dafür dass die übrigen
strippenzieher im land ungarischen
militärs lokalpolitiker und mafiosi
große chancen haben alternative macht
netzwerke zu errichten mit denen sie ihn
entmachten sobald er ihnen nichts mehr
bewegt es gibt durchaus einige leute in
der russischen führungsschicht die air
china und den islam als größte bedrohung
russlands ansehen und für welche der
besten der einzige mögliche dauerhafte
verbündete wäre wir dürfen uns auch
nicht zu sehr von der drohung mit
atomwaffen einschüchtern lassen
[Musik]
ich meine wenn du ein russischer
oligarch general oder offiziell erst und
ein präsident mit einem atomschlag
drohen würde der logischerweise einen
vergeltungsschlag nach sich ziehen würde
der dich deine familie und all deine
freund umbringt wäre es dir da nicht
egal wie viele milliarden oder millionen
wo gerade auf seinem bankkonto hast
diese leute mögen gierig sagen und
brutal aber sind nicht fanatisch die
russen neigen zu führerkult bewerten
jedoch ständig auch ihre individuellen
partikularinteressen putin selbst hat
auch kinder und enkelkinder im gegensatz
zu scholz märkten und makro er wird
seinen enkeln nicht einen bewohnbaren
planeten hinterlassen wollen allerdings
wird er wohl keine skrupel haben
verboten und der echte waffen
einzusetzen streuen und vakuum bomben
chemische und biologische waffen und
auch taktische kernwaffen natürlich
unter dem vorwand sie nur gegen
militärische ziele einzusetzen dieses
risiko muss einkalkuliert werden man
darf sich aber nicht durch die
apokalypse kolle blenden und ultimativ
einschüchtern lassen
[Musik]
sie ist einfach so abgedroschen vor
allem für all jene die sie noch gut aus
dem kalten krieg kennen aber lasst uns
zum abschluss noch kurz die rolle chinas
beleuchten im nächsten video habe ich
ein szenario bezeichnet in denen der
hohe preis putins für die ukraine
facebook in einem möglichen pakt peking
einkalkuliert sein könnte wir haben euch
jedoch auch immer gesagt dass russland
china nie und nimmer über den weg trauen
darf schon gar nicht bei geheimen
abkommen daher könnte dieses szenario
noch ein kleines aber entscheidendes und
das szenario beinhalten die chinesen
haben putin ganz einfach deswegen im
geheimen handlungsfreiheit zugesichert
was sie denken dass sie dabei nur
gewinnen können egal wie die ganze
geschichte ausgeht sie sind ja sowohl
auf taiwan als oxidieren aus und
versprechen sich durch den ukraine krieg
vorteil für beide expansionsvorhaben
denn wenn putins angriff den besten
gespalten hätte hätten sie die
erkenntnis gewonnen dass auch sie
leichtes spiel mit ihm hätten das ist
zum glück nicht eingetreten aber die
chinesen hat das sicherlich brennend
interessierte zweitens wenn putins
blitzkrieg erfolgreich verlaufen wäre
hätten sie durch die notwendige hohe
bindung von nato kräften in europa auch
direkte vorteile für die einnahme
taiwans bekommen drittens wenn russlands
armee in der ukraine aufgerieben wird
gewinnen die chinesen militärische
vorteile bei der besetzung sibiriens
viertens wenn russland noch mehr
kriegsverbrechen begehen und auch noch
mit einem punkt trägt rot könnte china
als entscheidender key player auf den
plan treten und dann als friedensmacht
die welt retten indem sie sich die als
die sowjetunion mit dem westen alliierte
dann könnte russland unter diesen
alliierten aufgeteilt werden die usa und
europa bekommt den westteil china den
osten sprich sibirien
[Musik]
in meinen augen ist sibirien für china
mittelfristig das strategisch wichtigere
und vor allem günstigere ziel waren wird
erst langfristig interessanter 2030 de
ski wird noch mindestens bis 2033 im amt
bleiben sie wäre hat genau das was china
jetzt braucht um noch mächtiger zu
werden rohstoffe
[Musik]
und es kann besetzt werden ohne auf die
dortige bevölkerung rücksicht nehmen zu
müssen da dort sowieso nicht so viele
menschenleben und china sie auch gar
nicht brauchen wird um die dortigen
rohstoffe auszubeuten sibirien ist eine
typische johanning für china und erst an
dem es hängt sich jeden tag an dem sich
russland weiter in der ukraine
diskreditiert militärischen überdehnt
und wirtschaftlich auslotet ein kampf
mit taiwan wäre aktuell sowieso sehr
teuer und würde ich hier noch keinerlei
strategische vorteile bringen auch vor
hoch sagte es hätten sich keine
rohstoffe es geht nur um die techno
industrie fabriken unternehmen und
menschen mit ihrem know how eine
invasion der insel würde diese
infrastruktur jedoch weitgehend
verwüsten die fabriken wurden zerstört
werden die menschen würden wie und auch
die unternehmen würden ins ausland
abwandern die chinesen hätten nach einem
verlustreichen krieg nur eine wertlose
pazifikinsel gewonnen und so dumm sind
sie nicht also wenn du wärst was würdest
du dir zuerst schnappen wollen sibirien
oder teilbaren aufgeschoben muss ja
nicht aufgehoben heißen so dürfen wir
bereits jetzt zeugen eines besonderen
schauspiels sein chinas außenminister
waren je sagte seine regierung habe die
entwicklung der ukraine frage verfolgt
und die derzeitige situation sei etwas
dass china nicht sehen will man müsste
die sicherheit das leben und das
eigentum der einfachen menschen schützen
und könne keine humanitäre krise
größeren ausmaßes zu lassen na klar
jeder hatte ja schon immer ausnahmslos
nur die sicherheit das leben das
eigentum der einfachen menschen im sinne
auf jeden fall dürften diese setzen
putin der für die widerspenstige ukraine
nach dem missglückten blitzkrieg ist
wohl die grosse variante ausgewählt hat
also die totale zerstörung der städte
ohne rücksicht auf die bevölkerung ganz
schön ins schwitzen bringen aber jetzt
seid ihr erst mal an der reihe was
würdet ihr an stelle der menschen in der
ukraine machen die waffen niederlegen
und euch in das von putin für euch das
system ergeben was würdet ihr tun wenn
seine truppen in euer land einfallen
würden welches wahrscheinlich noch eine
schwächere verteidigungsfähigkeit hätte
als die ukraine wo sich die ganze zeit
nur auf die usa verlässt welche jedoch
auch sagen könnten nun ein löst eure
probleme in europa doch diesmal selbst
würdet ihr euch in eure neue existenz
als untermenschen ergeben wie immer
freuen uns schon auf eure antworten auf
diese knallharte fragen aber im ernst
schreibt uns bitte in die kommentare wie
ihr die lage einschätzt und was ihr
bereit werte unternehmen damit wir
unsere freiheit nicht von der geiz ist
geil mentalität verblendete zum ausdruck
und schornstein heraus blasen was müssen
wir tun um den wahnsinnigen kräne zu
stoppen ich hoffe dass euch trotz seines
düsteren inhalt dieses video gefallen
hat was ja gibt es mit ein leichtes mit
euren freunden vergesst nicht dass ab
mit glöckchen um keines unserer videos
mehr zu verpassen natürlich freuen wir
uns auch jederzeit über eine spende von
euch mit der iss hält dieses projekt
weiterzuführen denn paypal link dazu
findet ihr in der beschreibung oder
diesem video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]